.
VIDEO THAT APPEARS TO BE RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS BANISHED TO A DARK
CONCRETE CELLAR FOR REFUSING TO
GO TO THE FRONT LINE IN UKRAINE.
YOU CAN SEE SOLDIERS DRESSED IN
RUSSIAN MILITARY FATIGUES,
PACKED INTO A SMALL WINDOWLESS
ROOM.
THAT'S WHY THERE IS NOT MUCH
LIGHT THERE.
ONE OF THEM EXPLAINS HOW THEY'RE
BEING TREATED.
LISTEN TO IT.
>> Translator: WELL, HERE WE
ARE.
THEY ARRESTED US.
THIS IS OCTOBER 2nd, 22.
WE ARE PART OF THE THIRD
BATTALION OF THE 488th MOTORIZED
RIFLE REGIMENT.
WE WERE ARRESTED FOR REFUSING TO
FOLLOW ORDERS.
YES, REFUSING TO FOLLOW ORDERS.
THEY SENT US TO A BASEMENT OF A
MILITARY UNIT.
ALL OF US ARE MOBILIZED SOLDIERS
OF THE RUSSIAN ARMY, CALLED UP
BY DECREE OF THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE THREATENING TO SEND US
BACK TO THE MEAT GRINDER, TO THE
SLAUGHTERHOUSE TO GET ROUTED BY
THE ENEMY.
WE REFUSED.
>> SO THIS IS HOW WE LIVE.
THIS IS WHERE WE GO TO THE
TOILET.
COVER YOUR FACES IF YOU'RE
AFRAID.
THIS IS HOW WE SLEEP.
WHAT A LIFE.
EVERYTHING HERE IS MOLDED.
WE'RE BASICALLY LIVING LIKE
BOMBS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING LEAKING FROM THE
CEILING HERE AS WELL.
>> CNN COULD NOT INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THE VIDEO.
BUT IT COMES AS PUTIN IS UNDER
PRESSURE.
HE IS SPEAKING TO HIS
COORDINATION COUNCIL SAYING THAT
THE CHALLENGES RUSSIAN FORCES
ARE FACING ARE SERIOUS AND
SIGNIFICANT, PUTIN'S DIRECT
WORDS.
SO SERIOUS IN FACT THAT THE
RHETORIC FROM RUSSIA IS RAMPING
UP.
A TOP OFFICIAL WITH THE PUTIN'S
SECURITY COUNCIL SAYING THAT
WITH THE CONTINUATION OF THE
SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION, IT
BECOMES MORE AND MORE URGENT TO
CARRY OUT THE DESATANIZATION OF
UKRAINE.
THIS IS FROM A TOP OFFICIAL ON
PUTIN'S SECURITY COUNCIL.
WHERE DO YOU GO AFTER WORDS LIKE
THIS WHEN YOU SAY YOU'RE
FIGHTING SATAN?
TODAY RUSSIA'S DEPUTY AMBASSADOR
TO THE U.N. CLAIMING, AGAIN,
THAT UKRAINE WAS CONSTRUCTING A
DIRTY BOMB.
THAT'S THE ACTION.
THE CLAIM WIDE LANE SEEN AS A
PRETEXT TO ALLOW PUTIN TO
ESCALATE TO NUCLEAR WAR.
AND TONIGHT PRESIDENT BIDEN
RESPONDING.
>> LET ME JUST SAY RUSSIA WILL
BE MAKING AN INCREDIBLY SERIOUS
MISTAKE IF IT WERE TO USE A
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON.
I'M NOT GUARANTEEING YOU THAT
IT'S A FALSE FLAG OPERATION YET.
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT IT WOULD BE A SERIOUS,
SERIOUS MISTAKE.
>> THIS ALL COMES AS WE'RE
GETTING UNPRECEDENTED AND
EXCLUSIVE ACCESS TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO RUSSIAN TROOPS ON
THE BATTLEFIELD.
THIS IS ACTUALLY WHAT PUTIN
DOESN'T WANT AND CAN'T AFFORD
FOR RUSSIANS TO KNOW OR TO SEE.
HIS SOLDIERS LOSING THEIR
FINGERS, THEIR LEGS, THEIR JAWS
BECAUSE OF COMMANDERS WHO
DECEIVED THEM.
AND RUSSIA SENT THEM INTO BATTLE
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO PLAN TO CARE
FOR THEIR INJURIES, WHICH IS WHY
THEY ENDED UP IN A BELARUSIAN
HOSPITAL.
THIS IS AN EXCLUSIVE REPORT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO SHOW IT TO
YOU IN JUST A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST NIC ROBERTSON IS OUT
FRONT LIVE IN KYIV.
YOU HEAR BIDEN'S WARNING TO
PUTIN SAYING IT WOULD BE A
MISTAKE FOR RUSSIA TO USE A
TACTICAL NUKE.
AND YET AGAIN TODAY WE HEAR THE
FALSE FLAG OPERATION, POSSIBLE
FALSE FLAG OPERATION BEING
PUSHED WHERE THE RUSSIANS SAY
UKRAINE WILL USE A DIRTY BOMB.
THAT IS SEEN AS A PRETEXT FOR
PUTIN TO GO NUCLEAR.
DOES PUTIN REALLY THINK THE WEST
WILL BELIEVE HIM ON THIS DIRTY
BOMB?
>> Reporter: I DON'T THINK HE
PARTICULARLY CARES IF THE WEST
BELIEVES HIM.
HE KNOWS THAT THIS IS A POINT OF
LEVERAGE.
HE KNOWS THAT THE WEST
UNDERSTANDS THIS THAT WHEN HE
USES THIS LANGUAGE, HE MAY
ESCALATE THE SITUATION.
THE UKRAINIANS DON'T BELIEVE HIM
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BUILDING A
DIRTY BOMB.
UKRAINIANS, WESTERN ALLIES DON'T
BELIEVE HIM BECAUSE THEY DON'T
BELIEVE UKRAINE IS BUILDING A
DIRTY BOMB.
BUT PUTIN'S ALSO APPEALING TO
HIS OWN DOMESTIC AUDIENCE, THOSE
THAT DON'T WANT TO GO AND FIGHT,
THOSE THAT ARE REFUSING TO FIGHT
BECAUSE HE'S RAISING THE STAKES
AND SAYING UKRAINE IS GOING TO
GO NUCLEAR ON US.
HE'S ALSO APPEALING TO PEOPLE
LIKE PRESIDENT XI IN CHINA, HE'S
APPEALING TO PEOPLE LIKE PRIME
MINISTER NARENDRA MODI IN INDIA.
HE'S APPEALING TO BIG
INTERNATIONAL AUTOCRAT BACKERS.
PRESIDENT PUTIN HAS SAID TO
PRESIDENT XI OVER THE PAST MONTH
THAT HE UNDERSTANDS CHINA'S GOT
SOME CONCERNS.
NARENDRA MODI, INDIAN PRIME
MINISTER, HAS TOLD PRESIDENT
PUTIN THAT THIS IS NOT THE TIME
FOR WAR.
PUTIN IS MAKING IT CLEAR TO THEM
THAT THIS IS THE TIME FOR WAR,
AND HE DOES NEED THEIR BACKING
BECAUSE UKRAINE IS OUT OF
CONTROL, AND IT'S GOING TO
ESCALATE.
SO PUTIN'S REAL APPEAL HERE, AND
HE HAS A HUGE TRACK RECORD, AS
WE ALL KNOW OF LYING, BECAUSE HE
SAID HE WAS NEVER GOING TO
INVADE UKRAINE.
HE KNOWS THE WEST DOESN'T TRUST
HIM.
>> ALL RIGHT, NIC, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FROM KYIV TONIGHT.
AND I WANT TO GO NOW TO
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN JIM
HIMES.
HE SITS ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, AND FRANKLY HE JUST
RETURNED FROM UKRAINE WHERE I
KNOW YOU MET WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY AND OTHER LEADERS
THERE IN KYIV.
NOW, WE JUST SHOWED THIS FOOTAGE
OBTAINED BY A GROUP OF
INDEPENDENT RUSSIAN JOURNALISTS,
THE SOLDIERS ARE IN RUSSIAN
MILITARY FATIGUES AND PACKED
INTO THIS DISGUSTING CELLAR.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY WERE
ARRESTED FOR REFUSING TO GO
FIGHT ON THE FRONT.
NOW WE CAN'T INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THE VIDEO, BUT DOES IT
FIT FROM YOU'RE HEARING FROM
UKRAINIAN LEADERS AND U.S.
INTELLIGENCE?
>> VERY MUCH SO.
THE UKRAINIANS HAVE CAPTURED A
LOT OF RUSSIAN TROOPS AND THEY
INTERROGATE THEM.
WHAT THEY HEAR AND OFTEN TIMES
WE'LL SEE THE REPORTS OF WHAT
THEY'VE HEARD IS THAT THEY WERE
FOOLED, THEY WERE TOLD THIS WAS
A TRAINING EXERCISE, THEY WERE
TOLD ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT LIES
THAT NOW HAVE THEM FIGHTING AND
DYING IN UKRAINE.
AND REMEMBER IN UKRAINE, UKRAINE
WAS A PLACE WHERE LOTS OF
RUSSIANS HAD COUSINS AND SISTERS
AND FRIENDS.
AND SO THE ONLY WAY, AND THIS
CONNECTS YOUR TWO STORIES, THE
ONLY WAY YOU EITHER COMPEL
SOLDIERS TO DO THIS IS EITHER TO
THREATEN THEM WITH THE KIND OF
CONDITIONS YOU SHOWED OR TO
DEHUMANIZE THE UKRAINIANS.
AND THAT'S OF COURSE WHERE THE
DESATANIFICATION COMES IN.
THESE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS KNOW
THESE UKRAINIANS.
>> THIS IS THE ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF PUTIN'S SECURITY
COUNCIL WHO SAID THIS.
AND I SIMPLY POINT IT OUT TO SAY
WHEN YOU ARE SAYING THAT YOU ARE
FIGHTING SATAN, THERE ISN'T A
WHOLE LOT WORSE TO GO.
SO IN TERMS OF YOUR WORDS,
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE AT
EXISTENTIAL END OF THE LINE.
AND THIS COMES IN THE CONTEXT
THAT TOP RUSSIAN OFFICIALS ARE
WARNING THAT UKRAINE IS GOING TO
USE A DIRTY BOMB, AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE A FALSE FLAG
ATTACK THAT COULD POSSIBLY ALLOW
PUTIN TO THEN ESCALATE TO TRUE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WHAT IS YOUR UNDERSTANDING RIGHT
NOW, FROM YOUR BRIEFINGS, FROM
YOUR TIME WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY?
IS IT A REAL POSSIBILITY THAT
PUTIN WOULD USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S HARD
TO PREDICT HIS BEHAVIOR.
AND HE HAS MADE -- SINCE
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR, HE'S MADE
EVERY MISTAKE THAT YOU COULD
MAKE.
AND THAT IS SOMETIMES THE
QUESTION IS, IS PUTIN PLAYING
THREE-DIMENSIONAL CHESS HERE OR
WHATEVER?
HE HAS MADE EVERY SINGLE
STRATEGIC AND TACTICAL MISTAKE,
AND HE'S LOST 70,000 PEOPLE AND
HE'S LOSING ON THE BATTLEFIELD
AND HE'S AT RISK DOMESTICALLY.
SO I THINK THEY'RE THROWING
SPAGHETTI ON THE WALL, JUST
PUTTING STUFF OUT THERE IN THE
HOPE THAT SOMETHING WORKS.
BUT HERE'S THE THING TO REMEMBER
ABOUT A DIRTY BOMB.
AND THAT'S OF COURSE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
WHAT HE RISKS, IT'S NOT SO MUCH
THE IRE OF THE WEST, AS NIC
ROBERTSON SAID.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
THE ONLY THING HE'S NOT GOING
FOR HIM RIGHT NOW IS HIS
PARTNERSHIP, OF SORTS, WITH
CHINA.
DO YOU THINK CHINA STAYS IN THAT
PARTNERSHIP IF RUSSIA USES A
DIRTY BOMB?
I DON'T THINK SO.
SO THE STAKES ARE HIGH FOR HIM.
>> YESTERDAY I SPOKE WITH
PUTIN'S FORMER SPEECH WRITER.
HE SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH HIM
WRITING SPEECHES.
HE SAID HE'S SEEN A BIG SHIFT IN
HIM OVER THESE PAST FEW YEARS.
AND HERE'S WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
HIS PERCEPTION OF PUTIN RIGHT
NOW.
>> HE IS BECOMING MORE AND MORE
EMOTIONAL.
PREVIOUSLY HE WAS VERY LOGICAL
AND VERY RATIONAL.
HE COULD CONTROL HIS EMOTIONS
EASILY.
AND HE IS EXHAUSTED.
>> MORE AND MORE EMOTIONAL.
AND HE SAID HE USED TO BE
PREVIOUSLY LOGICAL AND VERY
RATIONAL.
BUT NOW MORE EMOTIONAL,
EXHAUSTED, NOT ABLE TO CONTROL
HIS EMOTIONS.
ON THE INTEL COMMITTEE, HOW
CONCERNED ARE YOU RIGHT NOW
ABOUT HIS EMOTIONAL STATE, ABOUT
HIS RATIONALITY, FRANKLY, IN
MAKING DECISIONS?
>> WE'RE VERY CONCERNED BECAUSE
HERE'S A MAN WHO REGARDED
HIMSELF AS PETER THE GREAT.
HE WAS ONE OF THE GREAT LEADERS
OF RUSSIA.
WHAT HAS HE ACTUALLY DONE?
HE'S UNIFIED NATO, FINLAND AND
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT WE NEVER
IMAGINED.
HE'S UNIFIED NATO, HE'S
DESTROYED HIS COUNTRY'S ECONOMY.
AND HE'S SHOWN THAT THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY WOULD LOSE TO THE RHODE
ISLAND NATIONAL GUARD.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S ACHIEVED, THIS
MAN WHO REGARDED HIMSELF AS A
GREAT PERSON.
THE QUESTION THEN BECOMES WHAT
HAPPENS TO A DESPERATE MAN LIKE
THAT?
AND IT'S HARD TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
>> AND YET THERE ARE SOME IN
YOUR OWN PARTY WHO SAY NOW IT'S
TIME TO DO SOME SORT OF
NEGOTIATION, TO MAKE A DEAL WITH
PUTIN.
THE LETTER WAS WITHDRAWN THAT
DOZENS OF THEM HAD SIGNED,
SAYING THAT THE U.S. SHOULD
NEGOTIATE DIRECTLY WITH PUTIN.
BUT ONE PROMINENT MEMBER OF THE
CAUCUS HAS SINCE SAID TODAY THAT
HE STILL STANDS BY IT AND THAT
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN THAT
LETTER BACK SO HE DOES BELIEVE
THAT THE U.S. SHOULD NEGOTIATE
TO HIM.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> NUMBER ONE, THE UKRAINIANS
ARE WINNING THIS WAR.
NUMBER TWO, DO YOU TRUST
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
IF YOU COULD REACH SOME
AGREEMENT, DO YOU TRUST HIM TO
ABIDE BY THAT AGREEMENT?
NUMBER THREE, WHAT'S IN THAT
AGREEMENT?
BECAUSE THE PROGRESSIVE LETTER,
WHICH THANKFULLY THEY WITHDREW,
ITS OBJECTIVE WAS FOR A FREE AND
INDEPENDENT UKRAINE.
OKAY, THAT'S A START.
IT'S NOT JUST A FREE AND
INDEPENDENT UKRAINE.
IT IS THE RUSSIANS FACING
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR WAR
CRIMES.
IT IS THE RUSSIANS VACATING
EVERY SQUARE FOOT OF UKRAINIAN
LAND.
SO THAT RAISES THE QUESTION,
WHAT ARE YOU NEGOTIATING
TOWARDS?
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO --
WELL, I SHOULDN'T SAY WE.
>> YOU'RE ONLY NEGOTIATING IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE UP LAND.
>> EXACTLY.
I WAS IN KYIV 72 HOURS AGO.
FROM THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE TO
THE GUY WHO SERVED COFFEE IN THE
HOTEL, THEY SAID THIS ENDS WHEN
EVERY RUSSIAN IS OFF EVERY INCH
OF O